In this video, we're going to talk about setting up base materials and how we can get that
foundation down and make sure that's a doorway to be able to create instance materials, which
is going to help with our overall draw calls and overhead for our scenes.
So let's get started.
Some of the topics we're going to cover is a simple material setup and instancing those
materials.
First up, let's go and take a look at our spire material that we have set up and how
we can actually open up some of these parameters to be able to have full control of how they
look and feel.
And we'll keep this pretty simple because we do have a materials class, but this for
the most part just reminds you of the theory and the practice of this and how this actually
will help your overall scenes.
So let's go and take a look at this in Unreal.
So in our Unreal scene here, we have our spire here that we can play with.
So let's go and take a look at his material.
I'm going to double click on this material.
And we keep these concepts pretty simple, but so that you understand why and the purpose
of this.
So you'll see that we have a specular.
He's always going to be active and set to a 0.5.
The one thing you do need to keep in mind when working with a specular material is it
can interfere with the strength of your roughness.
So sometimes just lowering this to a simple zero can be kind of helpful.
So all your texture information, as in your roughness and surface information is pulled
from your roughness texture or whatever number of variables you're working with.
Now this is the material editor.
At this point, you should be familiar with this concept, as in, excuse me, with this
tool and how it works.
And in here, you'll see that we have several different modes for our material.
I'm just clicking right here, left clicking in the grid.
You can see that you can choose whether it's a simple surface, defer decal, light function,
volume, post-process.
Those are actually pretty heavy lifters in changing the dependencies of how this material
is going to look.
And also we have a blend mode, which will allow us to even push further how our visuals
are going to be for our material.
So we're going to keep things pretty simple.
We're going to have a surface opaque default lit.
All that's good.
Now remember, as you change things, such as turn things and make them more translucent,
they can't get expensive.
So keeping your materials in mind of exactly what you want, what your output is, is really
important because as your material gets more complicated, such as with translucency, things
can get expensive.
Now what we can do to maybe help that out a bit, because the draw calls look at each
one of your materials, is we can help out those draw calls a bit with some instancing.
And instancing can be very helpful.
Now you can have multiple instances off a parent or master mold material.
You can have multiple instances derived from it.
And you can have it so like there's 50, you can even go as far as 100.
That's a limitation based on your GPU.
But to be able to do that, to open this up, to open this master material, master mold
To open it up, to be able to do that, we have to actually open up our parameters.
So we have to go to each one of these textures, right click it here, and do a thing called
convert to parameter.
And we'll call this the albedo.
And when you create these, you can also have the option when you open up these parameters
to add a group.
So we can call this the albedo.
And I'm keeping this pretty simple.
In the most part, what we might want to do is maybe introduce a multiply.
In that multiply, we maybe have a scalar parameter, which is a more upgraded version of this constant
parameter here.
To get there, you can either right click a constant parameter and convert to a parameter.
Then we'll change it to a scalar parameter.
Or simply keep your finger on the S key and the left click and you'll create a scalar
parameter.
And then in here, we could call this a, you know, I'm going to maybe change the color
output of this individual texture.
Maybe introduce a three constant vector.
This will be for color.
We can keep it black and we can pull this albedo in here.
You can get a preview what it's going to look like.
You can see if we right click, start preview mode, you can see that we're all black.
So you have to watch out between add and multiply what you're going to get.
And in this case, we would set this to white.
And they'll see your color information come through.
And if you wanted to, let's stop that preview.
We can control maybe how strong that's going to be.
So with this multiply in place, we can maybe pull in the strength of that albedo.
By temporarily disconnecting this, moving this over here.
Simply make another multiply.
Put this in here.
This in here.
And then connect that right here.
And you'll see that it's dark at first, right?
So this parameter, we can set that to one or even higher if we wanted to.
And let's add this to the base.
And you'll see now it's still a bit dark, right?
Not quite exactly what we're looking for.
So as you increase your multiply, you'll see that it's going to magnify things.
So the nice thing about working with a scalar, we can keep things within a range.
So I can say, hey, man, I want my default to be 10.
I want my slider.
Or actually, that might be too strong.
We'll do like maybe a five.
And I want my slider minimum to be zero and my maximum to be five.
So this all depends how you want to pull this through.
But this gives you the magnification based on whatever color you've chosen.
And that's one way you can do it.
So there's multiple ways.
And whenever you make these, make sure you comment them out.
So you can say, hey, I want to comment this right here.
We'll leave the C key.
We'll leave this guy out just temporarily.
And we'll just say here, color experiments.
And there's multiple ways to actually match this up.
I just did this super generically.
And in our classes, you'll see me talk about, as well as other instructors,
how to set this up.
And this is just a quick way.
You could even just add.
But this multiply and add kind of act a little bit like Photoshop,
allowing us to stack.
But you have to keep in mind what kind of color output you're going to get.
And you can get that through a preview by right clicking,
which you saw me do just a minute ago for previews and so forth.
We could even lower this to maybe two if we wanted.
That's too dark.
Let's do something like that.
Or four.
There we go.
That's fine.
All right.
So that gives you a little bit of control.
Gives you an idea of how that works.
And you can also keep it simple.
This just depends on how much control you want of this object.
But if we are going to do this, again, we have to actually open up the parameters.
Convert that to a parameter.
Call this color overlay.
And we've got to put them in a group.
We're going to put them in that albedo group.
Do the same thing with the scalar parameter.
Want to give it a name, though.
We'll call this intensity color.
So color intensity.
Let's just put that there.
And just put that into an albedo group.
And then again, we want to open up each one of these.
Convert to a parameter.
Rough.
Yes.
And normally, you could put a multiply in here.
And you can choose scalar parameter.
I'll do this slightly quickly here.
Rough intensity.
Because you should have had these classes at this point.
Move that in there.
We'll set his limitation to.
And you can cheat a little bit.
Because when it comes to roughness, it's typically a 0 to 1.
That's really how it works.
But you can cheat a little bit with Unreal.
If we introduce a multiply, we can go a little bit higher.
And I actually like to work with a little bit higher numbers.
Instead of getting carpal tunnel and typing in 0.00.5,
that's the intensity I'm looking for.
You can cheat when it comes to the multiply
in this particular case.
And metallic, not so much.
So I'm going to go in here and put a 10.
We'll do a 5 as default. If we want to increase that,
we can set the minimum to 0 and maximum to 10.
So then we can go higher.
That's there.
And we probably have to mute this a bit,
because it's probably still too high.
But that's fine.
And we just set that to roughness there.
And we also have ambient occlusion.
We'll leave that.
We'll leave normal.
Now, normal, if you want to control this,
is a little bit counterintuitive artist-wise.
But what you want to do is use a flatten normal.
Sometimes I'll be lazy in my flatten normal.
I'll just simply put in a scalar and flatten this.
But the only problem is it works in a negative space.
So it gets a little weird.
So we'd have to actually flip that so it goes back
to a positive.
So since this works in an opposite direction,
so negative is pushing forward the way you maybe
have intended it, going positive numbers goes negative,
that's going to be counterintuitive.
So you have to actually use a 1 minus node.
Back, there it is.
I literally typed a node.
And I can put that in my flatness here.
And I would connect this to my scalar parameter.
And we'll call it normal intensity.
And I keep in this pretty basic.
Regularly, you would create a whole UV set
where you can control how many times the UVs are tiling.
In this case, since UV is very specific with his UVs,
we probably should do that.
Otherwise, you could really ugly fast.
But if you have a more encompassing texture
that is more generic and not really dependent on UVs,
you can actually play with that a bit more.
So I'm going to go and move this to the normal.
And in that normal, we bring that into the normal.
And in that normal, we bring that into the normal space
there.
There we go.
And again, we can control the intensity.
In this case, we can set the intensity to, say, 5
if you want to go really strong, minimum 0.
And then, say, we want to invert it.
We could do a negative 5 for actually,
I did that backwards.
Here we go.
Minimum is negative 5.
My bad.
That's negative 5.
And the maximum is going to be just a little 5.
There we go.
Cool.
And if you ever wanted to bring in your geometry,
just make sure you select your geometry in your content
browser.
With it selected, just click on the teapot,
and it will load it in this viewer.
All right, so with this all set up,
we want to make sure, again, we open up the parameters.
And this will be a normal.
We're going to create a normal group.
And we'll just add this to the normal group, too.
And we'll create a roughness group.
Add this roughness intensity to that roughness group.
Also, make sure this guy is connected to the roughness
group.
There he is.
For some reason, I thought I didn't do that.
And we'll just leave Albedo by himself,
because nobody cares about him right now.
So there we go.
We even got commenting.
We got this all set up.
And I would hit Say.
So I'm just going to apply in this case
so I can rebuild this for another course.
And I'm going to pull this across here.
And then now I can right click this particular piece
of geometry.
It looks like it's a little bright.
So we can probably go over that a little bit.
It's all shiny.
I actually kind of like it.
But we can change that in the instance, believe it or not.
So we'll do that in the instance.
And you can see the update on the fly.
So let's move this off to the side.
I'm going to right click here.
And we'll do Create Material Instance.
And we're going to call this mi for Material Instance.
We go across.
Let's get rid of that suffix.
Enter.
Open it up.
Now when we open this, you're automatically
going to notice the interface is quite different.
So I'm going to turn on my Albedo.
And that means I can switch any texture I want.
So maybe I'm working with this texture in Mixer, 3D Co,
or some other substance painter.
And Color Intensity, Color Overlay.
We got the Normal, Normal Intensity, Roughness,
and Rough Intensity.
All of this can be controlled on the fly.
So the Color Intensity, we can choose
the darkness of it if we wanted to.
And we can choose what color we want for it.
Apply.
And we can choose, make sure that's working here.
Maybe double check.
Got the parameter open.
Multiply Albedo.
We're good.
Cool.
Go back to our real-time spire here.
And we're going to Control Normal Intensity.
We can lower the Normal Intensity or increase it.
Now you'll notice nothing's happening here,
because I forgot I have to actually apply it.
So let's go on to Reset.
And we're going to go back to the real-time spire.
And we're going to have to actually apply it.
So let's go ahead and slap it on this guy.
And we can control the Color Intensity.
Now you'll see the updates.
We can choose the color that we want.
So in this case, we'll say, hey, man,
I want this to be more white in nature.
I want to give it a little red to it.
There we go.
Green, blue.
I had to check my work there, because I
noticed that I needed to go back a little bit.
I thought, why isn't it working?
Because I have to apply it.
It's crazy.
And then you can see all the color changes here.
And as we change those colors, let's get something that's
really going to show up on screen.
Blood, pinkish red.
And we can now change the strength of that,
which is pretty nice.
And even in Sequencer, if you wanted to,
you can open these parameters and animate this,
which is actually pretty cool.
And then we have Normal Intensity.
We can decrease the Normal Intensity or increase it.
You'll see it there.
We can go Negative or Positive, Inverting.
There's the Roughness Intensity.
You can see it there.
Working my full spectrum of my slider here.
And we can also choose to turn off my roughness
if we don't want to use it at all.
Decrease my roughness so there's no changes in it whatsoever.
And all that's available for you to play with.